de qué tan viable es que Los mercenarios
renuncian a su salario de Wagner y se
vayan por menos dinero a las fuerzas
oficiales rusas
Bueno ahí la cuestión es
se les permite esa posibilidad de
integrarse por contrato en el ejército o
las fuerzas terrestres del ejército ruso
pero claro hay que tomar en cuenta algo
con Wagner Wagner me da la impresión que
no es meramente una compañía mercenaria
es un cuerpo un cuerpo de élite se
sienten me da la impresión todos esos
mercenarios todos esos combatientes como
parte vamos a decirlo una gran familia
aunque sea una familia infernal pero en
que pregoyen es el que les ha protegido
les ha apoyado les ha pagado el dinero
en efectivo compensaciones equipamiento
etcétera y se sienten como en un cuerpo
de élite que claro se pierde eso si se
van a otra entidad y como has dicho pues
les pagaría menos en el ejército ruso
Así que habrá que ver cuántos de esos se
pasarán al ejército ruso los sin duda se
dijo inicialmente que aquellos que no
participaron de Wagner en el golpe
del viernes los viernes sábado Pues que
se les va a aceptar Si quieren firmar
contratos con el ejército y los que
habrían sido pues amotinados se les
Perdona que pueden volver donde sus
familias Habría que ver si ellos les
aceptan contratos con el ejército si se
han amotinado o irse a Bielorrusia a
velarrus usted nos habla de Wagner ahora
hablemos de Qué puede pasar dentro del
kremlin pues puti pasó Putin pasó de
considerar a jeffeny pregollón el líder
de esta milicia como un traidor a
permitirle que se vaya a velarusia
además hace una segunda alocución en
menos de una semana lo cual es bastante
extraño en el mandatario son estas
señales de debilidad de Putin
bueno Yo diría que el mero hecho de que
no pudieron detener a privoyen cuando
cruzó la frontera de Ucrania a Ucrania
ocupada por las fuerzas rusas a
territorio ruso ocupar la ciudad de
rosto en el río Don avanzar a borrones
al norte etcétera rumbo a Moscú no
pudieron detenerlo y intentaron desde el
aire con helicópteros de ataque leales a
Putin tampoco les derribaron varios
helicópteros un avión incluso de Mando y
control se habla de 39 tripulantes
muertos leales a Putin tripulantes
aéreos pilotos y tripulación de avión
Así que eso demuestra debilidad en mi
opinión y el hecho de que permitieron
que avanzara una columna de wagneras y
se dijo Ah creo que el ipex que está
seis horas de distancia al sur de Moscú
al seis horas por la carretera m cuatro
que va del sur Pues a Moscú y bueno el
hecho de que
fue lucachenko el que negoció el cese al
fuego no Putin Luca chenco que es
considerado ha sido considerado como
hombre de Putin un satélite etcétera por
debajo del todopoderoso Vladimir Putin
ya también me demuestra debilidad
hay numerosos factores me puedo halagar
alargar en el tema pero el hecho que es
contradictorio que dice que le ha
llamado traidor que le ha dado una
puñalada en la espalda prigollín a Putin
pero Putin ahora dice que puede exilarse
a Bielorrusia según el acuerdo ese que
dice Putin que lo va a cumplir eso sería
un símbolo debilidad porque un líder
fuerte trataría de no comprometerse y
más bien eliminar o detener de alguna
forma al traidor pero no está ocurriendo
eso y permitir a los de Wagner
sublevados potencialmente a escapar a
Bielorrusia belarus también para mí es
una señal de debilidad